In 1923, Mustafa Kemal Ataturk founded Turkey from the ashes of the Ottoman Empire.
His goal was to reorient society toward the West.
He abolished the caliphate, reformed the legal code, and changed
the alphabet.
He gave women equal rights and embraced the
separation of mosque and state.
For decades, the West took Turkey for granted.
Turkey was a NATO member and stood firm against
communism, terrorism and Islamism.
Turkey was among the first Muslim countries
to have a female prime minister.
It aspired to EU membership.
As a secular democracy, it
stood in contrast to most Muslim majority countries.
Recep Tayyip Erdogan changed this.
He declared his goal to “raise a religious
generation.”
Over 14 years, he curtailed free press and opposition.
He Islamized curricula, and pushed women from
the public sphere.
His is the anti-Ataturk.
Islamism is ascendant.
Secularists have been cowed into silence.
But is Turkey’s change permanent?
Some hope that when Erdogan goes, the old Turkey will return.
That’s wishful thinking.
Erdogan has brainwashed a generation, purged the military, and reshaped bureaucracy.
Plus, the opposition is incompetent.
The good old days are gone.
With or without Erdogan, Turkey's going to be a problem for decades to come.
Do you think secularists can rebound in Turkey?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us know what other topics you’d like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.